[Música]
olá todos né
quem gosta desse som né
detesto se eu fosse o rei do mundo eu
proibi o espectador
na verdade quando a gente fala do
despertador tem uma coisa mais
importante que é pensar nos nossos
adolescentes que existe hoje existe uma
guerra entre os pais dos adolescentes
mãe pai né bateram na porta e corda
acorda acorda pra quem pra escola
na verdade né nós temos uma contradição
hoje que é a falta de compreensão da
importância do sono principalmente nos
adolescentes e é uma coisa que nós temos
estudadas há bastante tempo estudar sono
é possível de várias formas
uma delas é fazer um exame que nós
chamamos de polissonografia que aqui tá
apresentado para vocês é um exame que a
gente olha microscopicamente o que está
acontecendo no cérebro das pessoas
e aí a gente pode inclusive identificar
domingo está acordado que tipo de sono
se está sonhando
porque quando nós dormimos ocorrem
várias coisas no nosso cérebro em algum
momento cérebro fica tão ativo como a
vigília como se a gente tivesse acordado
que é exatamente naquela fase que nós
sonhamos mas isso é difícil porque é um
exame complexo um exame caro o que a
gente tem feito é utilizado é uma outra
técnica que se chama actímetro um
aparelho semelhante esse que estou
usando aqui
esse time foi desenvolvida
ouvido na relação entre a universidade
empresa é uma tímida no nacional o que é
que esse é o time que eu faço eu tenho
um acelerômetro né é desenvolvido nessa
são dados lá da universidade federal do
rio grande do norte aonde né eu sou
professor e faço pesquisa e neurociência
de sono né e aí quando a gente vai olhar
é como é que se comporta ao longo da
nossa vida a gente vê algo é bastante
interessante
veja em cima vocês estão vendo é uma
régua de tempo então essa régua do tempo
e em baixo em azul
vocês estão vendo um período de sono ou
seja a fase de sono do sujeito então uma
criança geralmente dorme em torno de 9
horas ea criança vai dormir cedo
10 10 e meia ea porta 7 8 horas mas o
adolescente naturalmente biologicamente
ele está mudando seu corpo está mudando
inclusive aquilo que nós chamamos
relógio biológico
o relógio biológico do adolescente muda
a locação temporal do sono faz com que o
sono comece muito mais tarde
então é natural um adolescente ficar até
altas horas da noite no seu quarto sem
dormir e dormir mais tarde e necessita
mais de sono o adolescente porque ele
está em transformação o seu cérebro está
em transformação
então um adolescente é em média dorme
das horas e então ele dorme mais tarde e
acorda mais tarde porém o que ocorre é
no adolescente que vocês estão vendo
nessa terceira linha é que
biologicamente o som do adolescente é
mais tarde mas o horário das escolas na
faixa de idade da adolescente entre os
13 e os 19 anos a escola pela manhã e no
brasil geralmente começa às 7 horas da
manhã
então o que ocorre a biologia
manda o sono para mais tarde ea escola
rouba o final do sono e esse final do
som é importantíssimo
ele é importantíssimo para a
aprendizagem é decerto e o que ocorre
agora nesse momento além de ter a
biologia atrasando o som tem as próprias
redes sociais o que a gente tem olhado é
o que ocorre e por isso né a gente usa
na o actímetro né então o time deles
serve para registrar a atividade o que
vocês estão vendo aí em cima a hora do
tempo e em baixo é um dia o segundo dia
o terceiro o quarto eo quinto
vejam que logo nos primeiros lá até seis
horas não têm registro em azul e isso é
registro pessoal meu
aí lá praça um pouco seis horas começa e
tem um monte de atividade depois cai
fica atividade durante o dia depois
aumenta de novo nos outros dias e se
repete na verdade né esse aumento no
início no final é porque eu ando de
bicicleta vou trabalhar de bicicleta e
volta de bicicleta e em natal não tem um
asfalto liso então vibra muito e se
vibrar do guidão da bicicleta
libra mão e por isso que registra mas
com esse tipo de aparelho consigo a ao
longo de vários dias como é que está o
sono e é isso que a gente vê né então
veja aqui eu tenho um exemplo de uma
criança de dois a 12 anos
o que a gente observa se vocês olharem
esse gráfico o escuro é quando a criança
ativa
então veja que essa criança está
dormindo
nessa já para o escuro próximo de dez
horas da noite lá depois né de seis
horas começa novamente atividade todos
os dias
já no outro gráfico o que a gente vê o
adolescente de 14 anos a mais tarde ele
dorme mais tarde e acorda mais tarde e é
claro esse registro de um adolescente em
férias
então isso em férias e este é o registro
de um adolescente
durante as aulas veja que não tem
regularidade é uma bagunça generalizada
ele não tem horário para dormir
ele vai dormir tarde mas tem que acordar
muito cedo e isso faz uma privação de
sono a escola rouba o sono na noite
seguinte ele tenta recuperar e isso gera
um padrão de sono totalmente irregular e
o que é que essa irregularidade né
provoca no adolescente
primeiro uma baixa qualidade de som
ele vai ter sonolência durante o dia que
nós chamamos sonolência diurna ele vai
ficar sonolento na sala de aula ele é
sonolento nem no ônibus ele é sonolento
na van que leva ele pra escola mas
diminuiu o desempenho acadêmico
então esses adolescentes que ficam com
um padrão de sono mais regular tem baixo
desempenho por causa do sono
ele tem baixa capacidade de concentração
ele tem maior inclusive risco de doenças
cardiovasculares
imagina um jovem de 16 anos eu fazer uma
avaliação clínica e de cara tudo parece
que estava um padrão né de alguém que já
está com 35 e 40 anos de idade
esta é a grande preocupação agora por
que isso ocorre
então pra a fazer pesquisa a gente não
pode ficar só na generalidade sou só um
estudo comportamental
a gente quer buscar entender o que
ocorre dentro do cérebro é claro que eu
não posso fazer isso né
um adolescente mas eu posso fazer isso
experimentalmente com modelos animais
então num modelo animal eu não posso
criar a simulação da escola
então o que a gente cria uma simulação
de um dia diferente
então em vez de fazer um dia de 24 horas
e é natural a gente faz um dia de 22
horas 11 horas com luís e 11 horas com
escuro
é como se eu estivesse levando nem o meu
animal experimental né para marte o que
a gente vai observar no caso a gente
trabalha é conrado é inclusive uma parte
o trabalho foi desenvolvido aqui na
universidade federal da paraíba né no
laboratório de memória do departamento
de psicologia
a gente vê que o animal tem déficit de
memória
ele aprende - ele tem um comportamento
similar a um padrão de depressão ele tem
um comportamento né similar né a
ansiedade e o mais grave é que quando eu
vou estudar em detalhes o que está
acontecendo no cérebro desse rato
eu tenho uma redução da expressão de
alguns jovens que geram algumas
proteínas que estão relacionado com a
aprendizagem e com humor
então a gente consegue ver exatamente
uma evidência muito clara biologicamente
de que o sono do adolescente está
prejudicado
e isso está prejudicando o próprio
desenvolvimento é do funcionamento do
cérebro desse adolescente então por que
esse adolescente tem baixo desempenho
porque quem sabe o le senti ele tem
maior comportamento de risco ou seja ele
usa mais substância psicoativa ele é
mais agressivo ele tem menos
concentração então nós
a escola está roubando o sono dos
adolescentes e com isso nós estamos
prejudicando a principal questão que é o
papel da escola é o processo de
aprendizagem e à formação do cidadão
agora o que é que tem distral dinário
nisso que tem de extraordinário mesmo é
a solução uma solução fácil e nós
fizemos isso na universidade federal do
rio grande do norte eu sou professor de
neurofisiologia do curso de medicina e
lá as aulas começavam às 7 horas
claro eu briguei briguei liguei e
conseguir fazer a mudança
hoje nossas aulas
não começam mais sete horas começam né
a oito horas já tenhamos uma hora eu já
não tenho mais a estudante na minha sala
do menino
no início das aulas e simplesmente
porque eu liberei uma hora mais é claro
né o que a gente tá né colocando o
direito do adolescente dormir
então nós estamos nesse movimento no
sentido não dá mais pra gente dizer que
o gozo
nós temos que entender que
biologicamente o adolescente muda assim
como as suas características né do corpo
muda a voz nem a grande excepção dos
olhos mas o sono também muda ea gente
precisa respeitar e as escolas precisam
respeitar é uma forma da gente acabar
com essa guerra entre países e
adolescente então o direito a dormir do
adolescente tem que ser garantido
então por isso é que nós estamos
propondo
nós já fizemos o primeiro manifesto pela
ascensão para o sono para que a sugestão
pra escola organizada junto com os
professores diretores pais e os próprios
estudantes organizem horários que a
nossa sugestão é que o início das aulas
para aqueles que têm idade entre 13 e 19
anos
é que só a faixa do adolescente início
no mínimos a 8 e 30 já lançamos um
manifesto nessas neste ano né na semana
nacional do sono a gente fez uma
campanha nacional é no sentido de
atingir os educadores mas nós não só
queremos atingir educadores nós queremos
que os adolescente e os pais dos
adolescentes né no sentido de garantir o
direito de dormir nené e contra neodi
espectador
o nep em um nevo bons alunos e sonhos
felizes
obrigado
[Aplausos]